[Music]
life and death are the
same both can have value and
[Music]
purpose Shogun is something new to the
audience and hopefully something that
will be
groundbreaking
[Music]
[Applause]
when you think about how much research
time and how many creative minds it took
to create this it just blows me away
it's just amazing the scale of it I've
never worked with this many Japanese
people outside of Japan this this is by
far the biggest you know most elaborate
most detailed authentic show I've ever
done it's amazing so much of this show
is about bringing aspects of a far away
world to an accessible realm for the
audience it's just been truly a
inspiring and it's so exciting to see it
when a scene really comes together on
this
scale this season of Shogun is about
Blackthorn an English pilot who arrives
in Japan and through Lord tanaga and
Maro he's forced to come to terms with
the view of these people from this
unfamiliar
land I play Maro she is a Catholic and
is assigned to become the translator for
Blackthorn when he arrives and
throughout the season she's determined
and has to fight on her own I just am so
inspired by her
story it's a show about agency and
control over the path of One's Own
fate it's the story of taga he is a
prisoner of a political nature stuck in
ozaka waiting for his fate to be handed
down
something that was exciting for me in
the beginning was the idea that we two
could go on a journey with the character
John Blackthorne and we wash up on these
Shores with him and then it becomes
something else he has individualistic
Notions that he thinks he's going to
impress press upon this culture and
these people and he is a character who
had to forge connections Black Thorn has
to deal with the deficit between the
culture that was responsible for forming
his character and he is trying to learn
to not get his head chopped off by
people with very sharp swords well go on
then might as well be now this story is
set at the end of 16th centur of Japan
begins immediately after the death of
taon nakra the ruler of Japan has just
died my character is Kari isid I am the
political rival of
tanaga p is Mar's husband and I want a
happy life for both of us but John
blackon comes between us and messes
things
up
it is a story about how we make meaning
in our lives how we inhabit this world
that we live in it is filled with
visceral experiences and that is the
power of a great
story it's about that meeting of people
from a disperate range of culture gender
identity ethnicity language you find
common
ground
this is not where we die we should be
corpses but here we
[Music]
are